lorenzo dei sei il mio dj preferita che
sono sei a posto
quindi ragazzi oggi come ha detto marco
vogliamo fare un video un po strano nel
senso che mi era venuto in mente questa
cosa di chiedere i miei amici perché mi
reputo tali non sono colleghi anche noi
anche noi sì benissimo è un video dove
loro mi fanno domande 10 mi pare di aver
capito le hanno fatte loro in un cinico
e giampiero e cinque domande come una
parola che ricca e family friends
manderai calienti domande troppe belle
celano scelte loro io risponderò
sinceramente ad ognuna di esse impegnerò
veramente per risponde sinceramente non
ignori allora diciamo ha comunque la
figura di fa vj in questo senso una
figura positiva no c'è però essendo che
molto in alto
spesso la gente con figure molto in alto
un po un qualcosa che ha dato un turista
stronzetto no esatto e 4 a mente i suoi
amici alto contento di questo anche e
continuiamo a vedere oggi
mousavi che togliamo le mutande fa
vincere esatto ma la cosa c'è mi sto
sentendo aver voluto organizzare
costruita regala sì procedete poi è
un'iniziativa così stupido io ho detto
che mi alla prima domanda armi la cosa
più costosa ma non necessaria che hai
acquistato con i big money
beh dai non era così maledetta come
comanda questa prima allora allora una
volta una volta intendo due anni fa dai
o devi capire che ho fatto l'esame la
patente un sacco di 14 fallito di molte
di più
padova ma una volta lascia stare però è
bravissimo browser prime parti gli
applausi da mente vorrei parte ho
comprato una macchina non ho speso non
era affinati pomodoro rispetto
difficile senza la patente perché ero
convinto di passare l'esame però una
macchina ancora lì ma non le sa non ho
un altro è diventata non necessaria
perché hai fallito formali tra per amore
che vedere fate schifo devono per a
passare l'esame e poi guiderò se dio
appunto basta giovanna domanda hai mai
utilizzato la tua fama per ottenere foto
nude di ragazze o comunque utilizzato
questa carta per avere una marcia in più
non per aver fatto uno dei ragazzi e
giuro per la marcia in più
ovviamente se c'è senso allora io vengo
e rimorchiava scempio ed durante il
sesso no march va bene un penso non
usare anche indirettamente la cosa delle
suonavamo per io non ho mai avuto una
ragazza cosa per questo motivo che
benvenuti grazie facciamo la mauriziano
i frutti molto
comunque sì vabbè ma è ovvio perché
comunque tutte le tipe che mi hanno
mandata giù e ha speso molto e alla fine
della fame volente o nolente meritato no
è una cosa che ci siamo costruiti quindi
fa parte vuoi far finta di niente
neanche volendo che cosa faccio dico non
sono io
appunto può pensare a quello no no lo
capisco però magari una ragazza ti
contatta perché i piace esteticamente ma
noi sia l'accesso alle mie ragazze
voglio dire no in questo senso è infatti
bene come l'odio diamanti ragazzoni
perché non ne vanto ante volte ti cerchi
su google in un tir un mese non troppo
però ma siccome altri dico per dire ho
lette croci torino
perché dico perché intanto non su google
ma su marzo di dovere più importanti
come uno voglio cercare se sono uscite
interviste e molti altri video di
coopers è gente che montevideo più
trovati così e sono simpatici e anche
per vedere chi mi usa come tag nei loro
video tipo ho scoperto che non è un solo
fa e per successo ma non facciamo
diventare tutti ma andiamo alla seconda
domanda di giampiero queste ma ricorda
memoria
vai natività sei mitica magma guardala
voi no comodo no
come no ora frangia orribile ma è
piccola ma è orribile ragazzi c'erano
mai non riesco a guardarla in faccia
mangio io la francia la odio ma i poteri
è una pura è una proprio perché il
domani
adesso realizzando in bocca il posto più
conveniente dove ti hanno fatto passare
gratis perché sei fa vj più conveniente
del team honda aeroporto disco the cell
a disco tuna dei discutibili innovate di
milano perché altri possano minare in
mente si potenziano entrato bene a
calcio ma io non è cosa papà di gaia
buongiorno sono fuori norma le racconto
così si ma mica significa sì o no
eravamo già scavalli ero con robazzi ed
era già scavalli non puoi entrare così
vestito un male mi sono sperava libro
però mi bermuda e con le ciabatte e te
l'ho fatto si ama ragazzi e ci piacerà
anche skrillex quindi credibile
della sera persona che bada molto i suoi
soldi in senso buono prosciuga il tuo
conto in banca però con un acquisto
wow con un a cui oppure quella cosa
moltiplicata per motivo per esempio a
400 mila euro
nel mio capitano 400 state quindi
farebbe lui magari lavora come film del
terrore di una casa che però c'è una
casa che entri di cibo io non esco più
finché non muoio tipo quella del m viste
le case fantasma
se vi sono state radiate si tratta del
video di alex de ciccio ha detto vorrei
compra una casa della casa mi piace
l'idea era di grande e bellissima
camminavano poi si tipo michael jackson
che ha fatto è che non si però noi ci
battiamo
ti sei mai messo a piangere per via di
un video andato male e se sì quale no
piangerne online io sì a piangere cioè
con le lacrime vere non si amano ma
domani non di views ma perché successo
non solo dovuto io mi dispiace sto
rispondo io stato fermato in un tour è
il video sugli anime abbiamo fatto
diventare famoso che lei ha tanto l'ho
tolto appena aveva fatto 30.000 views ma
otto anni fa che era tanto però tolto
perché mai chiamato abbiamo fatto vedere
che si scrive il truzzo la seconda
immagine di questo fatto qua è malato
non solo io e voleva che io l'ho pagassi
per tenere nel video max7 cose strane
come imputati i genitori non mi sono mai
aperto con il ma non ho parole
quei video limonta veramente con l'anima
stati venditori ammalata tutto sto vide
uno sponsor martos però alla rai il più
quello dove siete posto più male no tipo
quello che non abbiamo registrato da c'è
un video che abbiamo registrato dove
così netta addosso dei fuochi
d'artificio non sono fuochi d'artificio
sono bengala solo che pubblicarlo dopo
capodanno era poco visto che c'è gente
che si fa male queste cose ma lui
esperto lo vedete non riusciamo a farlo
votare riusciremo a farlo ma non c'era
non posso pubblicarlo perché
desensibilizzati avete capito
nel senso che sensibilizzare
sull'argomento qui quello mi dispero che
un video incredibile e loro sanno solo
che è mamma mia non sono cosa pubblica
come mi dispiace un fatto piangere però
nord hydro piangere da lillo di lillo
smerda di adesso dicendo tutto il peggio
di te magari dicendo anche una brutta
azione che fatto nella tua vita
mammamia pro ha iniziato a fare video
facevo veramente schifo fa schifo
quindi prima dicevano che tipo mi
esaltavo per niente alla narrazione
macero molti mi facevo lo sanno solo
fare genova avevano ragione da vendere
ma nel campo youtube la tua vita cioè di
qualcosa di brutto che hai fatto che
qualcosa di brutto che offrono anche con
l'esempio acer un bambino un po
grassottello non una volta che ho fatto
un video con treni ne parla valori e no
aveva fatto contro di me c'è il sito si
chiama iodio fa vj no
un sacco di gente ce l'ha fatta la
reaction tutti alle fatta prato e
l'avevo fatta anche io perché questo
video era già virale cielo che
conoscevano già tutti allora ho detto a
bella faccia anche mi dispiace aver
fatto quella rieck per quanto io in quel
video non lo prendo per il non dico
niente contro i due guardino in sé il
rispetto
io non gli ho detto niente contro in
quello che dispiace perché comunque
poter evitare di farlo anche se non ho
detto anzi quelli di quel video io l'ho
detto ho detto pure una roba del tipo
ragazzi
però comunque farvi video reaction e mi
sono sentito un con formale che vedo
per quanto fosse una cosa in realtà ma
non è che l'hai fatto perché volevi
sembra che buon grado di abito guardano
al punto di vista malizioso no non l'ho
fatto con una volta una vera 90 per una
volta nella mia prima relazione è il pm
è l'amore morboso per quanto fosse anche
l'osso e giusta eravamo entrambi
morbelli perché c'erano piccoli peggio
del peggio
eravamo piccole ero un inesperti e
quindi c'era questa morbosità è che poi
nel tempo siamo maturati
quindi quando io andavo da qualche parte
lei mi dice vai perché noi no perché
vela quando è andata anche participer
che va via perché una volta era andata
in discoteca e tipo era andata a tutto
mezzo spanciata una manciata vuol dire
che però era ricorreva dal che poi è
quindi io per guardare la rai per
diventare nostro per uno ho fatto una
cosa incredibile io gliel'ho fatta
pesare in modo incredibile controllava
il mio profilo facebook quotidianamente
e lo facevano anche i nostri mosso
io mi sono sono entrato nel profilo di
un mio amico di facebook che aveva
parlato il prof però solo per quest'anno
perciò stata una entrata nel proprio
listino mio amico di facebook mi sono
scritto un messaggio sul mio profilo
quindi a lorenzo studio scritto ma
perché ho visto questa foto di dalla mia
ragazza che va in discoteca così è
successo qualcosa tra di voi la mia ex
ragazza in tempo zero era sul mio
profilo a leggere quel messaggio che io
mi ero auto scritto e mi ha chiesto
scusa su whatsapp basse o facebook
non so se applaude fare cioè allora però
è geniale
ammettilo però il matera pro incredibile
quanto anche la cattiveria non riesce a
essere già troppo capire cioè alla fine
tu non volevi farle male vorrei solo che
letti di share
la verità sì ma stando non è però il mio
massimo mi viene in mente niente
un applauso dove c'è una volta tira al
piccolo lorenzo morboso di me ultima mia
domanda secondo te quanto dovrei giocare
a the sims per avere il tuo conto in
banca
giorno 8 ore e o 200mila si mollano che
sembra sono un fenomeno sono previsti
tre di questi giorni non ho fatto il
call commentato programma immagini di
sabato bello però ci sono felicissimo
adesso giusto che si informa l'ente non
ho mai fatto il calcolo in giornata dai
due giorni forse tre sono troppi d'agrò
io sono comunque ti dice se anche
giorgia simpson di potermi dare uno dei
simboli più buio trapianti il tè di
adesso e il tè dell'inizio sono troppo
differenti come mai questo cambio è come
dire se ti sei reso conto che non ti
piace più
ma questa è la nostra danza pro infatti
fuori soltanto sapete questa cosa è che
allora quando dobbiamo fare il 2 di
questo video e faccio la domanda più
schifosa nel mondo per maschi cioè io
pensavo fossero west ma va bene quando
facevo i primi video io urlavo veramente
tanto e mi esaltavo che mixa invitarti
no
giuro giuro su dio non riuscirei a
riandare a rivedere e limitarmi a quelli
di ragazzi grazie per aver deciso di
scopa la finiamo il mio padre non riesco
edificio colpito castello a quella ok
non riesco a farlo giuro convegno viene
ridicola stringe ma perché così la cosa
era perché noi facciamo noi facciamo
quella che praticamente non lo schermo
avanti allora ci si stia parlando
quindi ragazzi vi ringraziamo la
partecipata questo li ringrazio aveva
decimato questo video
se volete ancora a video mettetevi in
viaggio e mai a mettere di mezzo è
finito iscrivervi al canale anche i miei
amici che lascia in descrizione è
servita agli schieri e c'era un
possibilità della regal aspetta aspetta
prima di chiudere credibile gli otto
falli gay mi dà fastidio continuo fare
sta cosa davvero
[Musica]